I want to pull up this article from
bounding an account that's awesome dude
yes Godzilla actor Brian Cranston well
Brian Cranston is well known for a lot
of things claims he has white blindness
says he needs to learn and change in an
interview with the LA Times promotes
upcoming role as Charles Nichols in the
stage play power of the sale he revealed
he suffers from what he calls white
blind blindness and advocated for limits
on Free Speech what
what uh okay it's a privileged Viewpoint
to be able to look at the clan and laugh
at them and belittle them for their
broken and hateful ideology blah blah
blah you get the point you know this
really is this is he doesn't actually
believe any of this no he's being held
hostage exactly he's being held hostage
by his by his manager by his agents by
the industry he needs to continue to be
a part of I'm afraid Ben Shapiro I
implore thee we must save this man we
must give him an opportunity to say all
that stuff was because they made me say
it I just want to make films and we'll
be like yeah you're cool right on we're
a fan or is he such a capitalist yeah
they are they're just hyper capitalists
yeah who are like you know what if I
have to do this to make the money I'll
do this to make the money is he is he
possibly worried that his last two or
three movies didn't go so well and that
if he does this he'll be on front page
he again
Breaking Bad was a terrible script what
I'm just going to say that now
what were the last films he produced
well I'd have to look I haven't seen
anything from him yeah the Trumbo movie
2015 was not great he he killed him off
in act one in Godzilla look they're real
yeah I can't give specifics but we can
look it up but but it is inarguable that
he has been as relevant as he was when
Breaking Bad ended he's not then it
feels like almost so you've got the El
Camino the Breaking Bad movie okay fine
I love dogs you know the one and only
Ivan ladies night is something else
maybe it was the getting cast of Zordon
and Power Rangers that did him in
and I think you give him the opportunity
and you give him a path of success but I
wonder how much of what people are
chasing after his legacy and so the
issue is these people who live in the
cult genuinely believe that's the real
world and they View
actual America as a foreign entity and
something to be feared or something not
legitimate whereas you know the way we
described it especially yesterday
talking about the Civil War with um
Stephen uh Marsh there's a there's a
multicultural democracy in the United
States and a constitutional republic
they're at War they're at odds with each
other but the woke democracy is not the
real mainstream America it's something
weird and new that emerged in the past
15 or 20 years that's held in place by
the media that promotes it daily like
you don't realize that your average
neighbor does not believe the stuff that
you're watching on the news or that
you're seeing in these television shows
the average neighbor across from you is
a lot more reasonable than you would
think but they're held in these beliefs
are held in place by the mainstream
establishment press which has you know
your television holds a lot of weight in
your house the social media that your
kids look at holds a lot of weight you
know a lot of times when you talk about
when we talk about CNN like you'll talk
about the we talk about they rag on the
ratings of CNN right it's like it only
got 800 000 views this this episode
right I'm like yeah but these views are
parroted by celebrities each of who has
hundreds of millions of followers and
that pushes it outward to the general
public that's a good point they measure
only three million views but how many
retweets that show how many more views
that's a calculation that hasn't been
accurately done how many of the average
celebrity just watches CNN parrots those
beliefs and then every one of their
followers is uh you know or how many
Brian Cranston has an agent who comes up
and says look man you got to come out
you got to say this stuff okay it's
going to be big you're going to get a
bunch of attention and he's like oh okay
I got a feeling he runs his agent and
that he actually got brainwashed I saw
it happen to a few other people where
one morning they wake up and they're
like yeah yeah whiteness is a problem
yeah I think LeBron James had happened
too all of a sudden yeah they just want
money you go to enough of those uh those
con those uh you know those seminars
they make you attend to if you work for
the government and I'm sure you know
more than a few of them do end up
starting to fall prey to it very
prevalent in Hollywood oh yeah
and those stories Tim like I see like 20
of those a day when I'm looking when I'm
when I'm looking up stuff to talk about
like a lot of those I'll skip them I'm
like you know what it's it's so obvious
like we could cover that every day and
I'd be like do I really need to rag on
this yeah you know the weirdest thing
too is I'm sure you can go to uh Brian
cranston's um uh history and find a
whole bunch of racist and off-color
jokes and offensive comedy and
transphobia I mean there was uh someone
mentioned I saw on Twitter
SVU with uh you know NBC law or SVU and
that the main character Benson has has
been severely transphobic in a bunch of
different episodes or something I don't
know if that's true yeah because I know
that often these people lie or
exaggerate but I wouldn't be surprised
because it was a very different world 15
years ago the culture shifted I wonder
if this is actually you know he's got a
crisis management firm risk assessment
and they're like you know you did these
episodes of Malcolm in the Middle these
could come up and bite you in the ass if
you come out now and and become devout
you'll be safe there are absolutely
examples of that and and in Hollywood if
you're if you're the most vocal about
you know being a sort of a male feminist
or any of these things never trust a
male family you have the you have the
worst history of you know dating and
past and things like that so that is
that is a rule I think in cranston's
case it literally is he was less uh uh
popular he's just less part of the
Zeitgeist he was fading yeah and he said
how can I get back on the front page
that how's it I think he's I think it
was that something so he decided to
figuratively self-immolate yes that's
right he was like I know
that is exactly what happened in my
opinion look at James Gunn got uh he he
had his tons of tweets that were really
creepy uh that we stuff we can't even
talk about on here and if you're part of
the establishment you get a pass because
what Disney did is they fired him DC
hired him and then Disney quietly
rehires him for Guardians of the Galaxy
3
I I wonder if it actually played out
um very very favorably for him I wonder
if he was actually quote unquote fired
by Marvel James gone I think it was Mike
cernovich who pulled up these tweets to
make a point about cancel calls Joe's
after Rosie O'Donnell right and Rosie
O'Donnell or Roseanne or Roseanne
Roseanne so uh you know he pulls up
these tweets from these like James Gunn
used to make those uh those movies those
really like gross horror films or
whatever they were called yeah and so he
has these really off-color offensive
jokes and I'm like and he's trying to be
an edge lord it's whatever but of course
it creates a media frenzy by quote
unquote firing him he was able to work
for for Marvel and DC you get to do both
you have to do both and Peacemaker came
out Great Peacemaker is fantastic we
loved it and um shout out to uh have you
seen Peacemaker oh yeah that's great so
uh I don't wanna I'm not gonna give too
deep of a spoiler but if you don't want
to hear it you're being warned I don't
think it's a spoiler I just want to say
the villains in that show are the
establishment Democrats I'm not even I'm
not even kidding they give a speech and
I'm just like climbing alarm with them
that's like back to fact or like
what is this
it was climate alarmism mixed with Max
mask propaganda yeah uh disguised as
aliens coming from another planet and
then they're the villains they're the
bad guys and I'm like I I actually
thought they were gonna try and pull
some like it turns out you know this
this whole authoritarian worldview is
the right idea but they're the bad guys
and I was like you know gotta respect it
you know what we got to do create a
movie where we've already as a species
with learn how to withdraw the carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere and fix the
climate change thing to create graphene
with it and we're building new materials
but now we're competing with trees for
the carbon dioxide and it's a new
problem and the trees become the trees
become sentient immobile yeah but that
way it'll implant in people's minds like
hey it's not that big of a problem by
the way climate change we can fix the
climate if we get proactive about it
well well to get a little bit more
broader it is a big problem that we can
fix right to get a little bit more broad
on your point this is the purpose of of
culture is um run hide fight for
instance was about like standing up in
defiance like you know fighting for what
you believe in and saving people and
things like that these are cultural
messages it was um you know I haven't
seen it but I've seen the trailer and
there's like this young girl she's being
trained how to use a weapon stuff like
that there's there's a photo going
around of kids in Wyoming being in a gym
with airsoft pellet guns uh I'm sorry
not Airsoft with CO2 compression rifles
and I'm like my my joke about it was I
am disgusted and offended these children
should be outside with 22s putting them
in a gym with CO2 what are you doing
give them a 22 come on it's it's but um
the the establishment Democrat activist
review is shrieking children with guns
and there's like there's this video from
Libs of tick tock of a guy screaming
what are you insane and I'm like yo guns
are things like we we used to teach kids
how to be safe and respect them and
understand them and I was I think that's
a good idea so when you make a movie
that shows someone teaching you know a
young person how to use a weapon that is
creating the idea it's planning in
people's minds this is a this is a part
of life it's a normal part of life
that's the purpose of building culture
so you're writing yeah not a movie about
showing kids how to make guns but in the
movie The Character you love is showing
kids like is teaching a proper technique
and so then you understand that these
things are a normal part of the world so
and your in your view about Solutions
towards climate change and stuff like
that making movies showing possibilities
opens people's minds up too things they
may have not considered before which is
why it's so important if you seed
culture only to the left the woke you're
going to get movies like men have you
seen the new craft
the craft you know you know the original
the craft oh I know all about it you've
seen the new one yeah it was what it was
uh I don't even think you can call it a
movie no it was it was a a grouping of
random woke PSAs that don't seem to go
together at all the cast of spell turn a
guy gay or something I'm just like this
is not a movie it makes no sense but if
kids grow up watching that stuff their
brains are gonna be all jumbled up and
broken from this nonsense one of the
biggest producers in Hollywood uh was
caught in an interview saying he didn't
know any female directors even even
though a female had just directed a
movie for him wow and so of course he
got called out semi-cancel for about 10
out 10 hours and then back back and he
was back because he's such a big
producer and so his his sort of uh uh
you know his way of fixing things was to
put a bunch of female movies into female
directed movies into production the
problem is he didn't go and oversee
those movies the same way that he did
his male Direction he wouldn't be
allowed to he let these women go on set
and and and and you know by themselves
and and the movies failed black
Christmas in the crowd that's so bad and
it's and it's honestly really sad and so
all he well while he was applauded for
hiring all these female directors the
truth is he let them fail that's like
Biden's Afghanistan and withdrawal are
you familiar with uh
are you familiar with kicker guard story
about the clown no uh a fire breaks out
backstage at a theater and the clown
runs on stage to begin to warn the
audience of the fire and they all begin
laughing he then becomes more erratic
and extreme no you need to understand
they all laugh even louder and he says I
think the south of the world will end
with people believing it's a joke or
something that effect and I wonder if
you know I think about that when I see
this guy he he puts these female
directors in play just because they're
females doesn't oversee them the movies
are abysmal and flop and then everyone
cheers for him I wonder if what's
actually happening is the people in the
audience know there's a fire they don't
care though because they're all worried
about being the one person to not clap
while everyone else is clapping one of
the female writers on one of the two
movies started to talk about this uh
phenomenon on Twitter and quickly
stopped oh yeah you know was sort of
encouraged not to do that anymore you
know is that the girl that was talking
to Jeremy Hamby the quartering I saw a
good diet I don't I don't I don't think
so Jeremy's terrific she wrote um the
girl that's writing The Witcher I think
decided to strike up a dialogue with
Jeremy on Twitter or video chats so they
were really talking about I was like hey
yeah diversity is important but within
like one skin color you can have a lot
of different cultural diversity don't
forget that when you're creating well
well uh well no good yeah
the producer went further and created a
deal with Amazon to make low low budget
uh horror movies where he could get his
diversity quote quote as met so that he
could go back to making Halloween with a
white male does it actually have quotas
or is a personal thing of his it's a
little uh it's all it's all it's all all
it's all part of the it's all part of
the unspoken rule of Hollywood that's
now more spoken to be to be frank it's
like the identity politics version of
like Wes Craven saying he'd only do
horror films so they'd let him make a
classic Love Story yeah and he does what
they say the things they request of him
uh with no passion for it whatsoever
although I love the new Joker movie uh
you know uh the uh Todd the director uh
he wanted to make Taxi Driver yeah
that's what he made so he made yeah
let's just make a good movie and call it
Jokers Todd Phillips you put it in you
put it in a joker storyline and now you
get 70 million dollars to make the movie
instead of seven 55 million dollars made
a billion without China but Joker was
awesome it is it is Awesome Taxi Driver
is awesome but that's the trick right
it's it's happening with the new Batman
what's the new Batman movie the new
Batman movie is a 1970s it's you know
new American Cinema movie housed under
Batman now hopefully it's great that's
the that's the pitch yeah yeah but there
I think it will be because they're
letting Matt Reeves have run of his
production whereas the every other
Warner Brothers production they've done
they've interfered so heavily that's uh
that's a that's a party line right uh
who knows but that's the that's what
they're pitching uh uh and and Robert
Pattinson is a great actor yes you know
so the lighthouse Joker was I saw Joker
in theaters the media tried destroying
it they claimed it was incel yeah that's
why I made a billion dollars and but but
I went to see it and it's a it's a it's
really amazing how what the movie is
just the uh for I hope everybody's seen
it because that no I haven't seen it but
tell me I've watched so many times I've
seen it yeah I've seen a lot of Clips
pending is like it's I've seen the end
it's not action it's not I mean there's
action but Terror it's not superheroes
bro the ending is just psychological
Thriller edge of your seat shaking the
Joaquin Phoenix's performance my heart
like left for my chest in that final
scene and I was just like I gotta watch
this movie again wow it was amazing and
and it was it was you know for what it
was you say it's like taxi driver with
the joker storyline but still it did
Joker very very well as the Joker
character yep I would I would love to
see them use that version of The Joker
in in future iterations of of DC uh
films because that is an excellent Joker
he would fit within the Matt Reeves uh
version of those characters I don't know
if he would fit as well into the
standard DC EU given that it's far more
uh we denies no he would he it would be
amazing I'd rather see him in mattress
look I watched I watched The Dark Knight
recently and that version of The Joker
is absolutely incredible but very
magical right like how he pulls these
things off like all of a sudden he's got
two fairies rigged with explosives like
how did the Joker do that why are people
working for this guy who's broke he
stole money from the mob but he's he's
he's he's Reckless so much so that the
the mob guy Maroney I think it is he's
like I can't do this craziness I'm gonna
help the police now it it was it was an
excellent portrayal it was a fun movie
but it was magical this version of The
Joker they actually made it make sense
why are people following him ideology
because he was bucking the system and
he's out of his mind but people are like
I don't care anymore I absolutely love
it I think it'd be fantastic that makes
so much sense about why people why
Jokers are following in Gotham City
because Gotham's always been like
post-apocalypse it's basically like the
worst New York could become and you can
see that's great great observation I
actually like Batman Begins more than
the Dark Knight visually because I think
it actually captures what Gotham is
supposed to look like once it became the
Dark Knight and then the Dark Knight
Rises it just became New York and
Chicago mixed together whereas there was
far more uh a far more ethereal dark
tone here's what really gets me with
with Joker is the people protesting the
not the one percent they're outraged
they're they're their their lives are
miserable there's crime and they're
driven by ideology so when I think of
superheroes having to fight crazed
masses I'm like I actually understand
how you can't reason with far-left
extremists on the ground smashing
windows they're they're blinded by
hatred and zealotry and as a superhero
you're sworn to protect them yeah how
does Batman fight them he doesn't not
real not really well no Batman and give
some TBI he bashes their skulls in and
leaves them rotting shivering on the you
know the guy stealing the loaf of bread
and Batman the meme oh yeah yeah but but
I'm thinking about how they would do the
new Joker in in a future Batman movie is
the followers of the Joker are just
ideologues who are like you know Bruce
Wayne is corrupt the Batman supports the
police the police are crooked this
system needs to be torn down world baby
from the ash executive From the Ashes of
the old we shall build a new and the
Joker is the one to do it and then you
get order the Batman I think that Hong
Kong there's uh elements of like quarter
vowel story being brought into this
meaning that there's a lot of
possibility that the the Wayne's end up
being corrupt in the amount in the new
interpretation of the film which could
lend itself to that even better uh
because you know he can't fight back as
Bruce Wayne then because his parents are
his and and you know like in the Joker
Thomas Wayne looks kind of bad yep so I
I think I'm so impressed with with Joker
and uh they've done like Jared Leto come
on you know no disrespect I think you
know I don't know about that weird stuff
he's doing with those women or whatever
as well as weird stories about him in
Hollywood but uh uh Fight Club big fan
him as the Joker not so much so in
Batman are they is the Joker who's up
against the one percent like against the
Wayne's because they're part of the one
percent because that's the cool
storyline too or the people that follow
the Joker are they against the Wayne's
have they focused the hatred onto the
wings okay in the film he thinks Thomas
Wayne is his dad
and he's he's just schizophrenic and so
he's this angry angsty deranged guy who
snaps and there's some sympathy for him
the way he's mistreated and abused and
how he goes off but the protesters just
think the system is broken and they see
this guy who goes on TV and says it to
the world and now he's got a he's got a
following and now the Joker from that
point becomes arrogant and and when he
says like now I see the humor in it I'm
like that is such a good Joker it's uh I
would love to see his Evolution into
legit super villain how his followers
support him because they agree with him
because they're driven by ideology
fantastic do you like the idea of them
doing it with William Defoe as like an
as like a faux Joker like a three Jokers
type storyline from the comics uh I
didn't think I didn't like that like I
don't want it to be any more like the
comics I wanted to be like Nolan made it
it was basically crime dramas uh I don't
need it to be uh superhero-esque I need
it to be more like a standard Thriller
the way they did did Joker if they went
ultra realistic like Joker doesn't have
magic powers where he can rig a fairy up
but then you you deal with you know the
Batman or other superheroes struggling
to deal with someone who's got such a
large following you don't know who is
supporting him or where you don't know
how like what he's doing and there's
something to be said about people who
don't know how to play a game and
they're difficult to defeat so if
anyone's like plays poker there's a
certain difficulty in playing poker
against someone who has no idea what
they're doing they make weird bets yeah
you don't know if they're bluffing and
then they play 2-7 off suit and they hit
a full house and you're like we got it I
saw the two and the seven on the board I
thought they'd never played and they win
so having that erratic behavior of Joker
would be a really interesting you know
they could take that version we've got
to be really interesting against Bruce
Wayne who's where he like where Joker
releases like a bio weapon and can blame
it on the bat
well I don't know about come on that's
the perfect
little bow to put on this conversation
not realistic well that's like that's
that's a joke about that I I get it but
you know when I thought it was funny I
just said in writing I suppose I didn't
understand because I'm like that's the
opposite of what I just said yeah it was
something else so I'm saying like you
have this Joker who's just a mentally
ill guy Who develops the following how
could that manifest realistic chaos
against the Batman you know or a Justice
League he's like I I can calculate
anyone's actions but this man is totally
erratic I can't I can't pick his newest
move he would have billionaire followers
he like like the far left he'd have he'd
have patrons who are ultra wealthy and
they would get word of like how to
support the Joker and they would be like
yes the system must be torn down and
that's how he he would develop these
crazy Joker lives matter he'd be like
you'd see like the Joker's face painted
on like you know what is it the stadium
you know they'd have like a joker flag
of the stage just a rich guy who's
telling the Joker what to take down
because then he can bet stocks against
the company or or or he'd be a good one
a rich guy trying to manipulate the
Joker thinking his craze you know can
harm companies that would benefit except
Joker smarter than that he may be crazy
but the Joker ends up manipulating him
back taking his money oh man I I think
they could do a lot of great stuff
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel Monday through Friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time